[lit music]
Aah
Welcome everyone, to some more VR chat.
Ya guys know how to play this?
How's it going, broskis?
I have arrived.
What's up?
What's up bro? Hey, good song.
Oh, you're new?
I'm new- I'm new too.
That's awesome, dude.
Wha- It took you a month to set it up?
Hey you look at that boys.
Oh, hell yeah.
Have you guys ever heard this song?
Nooooooooah
Oh, wow.
I'm in Japan.
And it's snowing.
Wow. And I'm PewDiePie.
Oh, god. Stop.
Hi.
[Sorry, guys, I don't know Japanese. I'm not a weeb.]
It's so *oof*ing weird.
Aaaaah, I'm cringing.
Come out with your hands above your head.
What happened?
What the *oof* does that mean, MasterChief?
MasterChief
I killed Bowzette, I'm so sorry.
I'm sorry.
She was a thot, she had to die, I'm sorry.
[Pewds making weird sounds]
That's what e-girls get.
My name's PewDiePie. I'm the thot destroyer.
Dude, I had saved your life. How about a thanks?
MasterChef
Oh, sorry.
I can't high-five! I got guns in my hand!
Wait. Is blue our team? Where is our team?
Hey- Hey frog. Let's go, guys.
Ah, it's PewDiePie, thank you very much.
Ah, ThE tHoT iS cOmInG
Careful, boys.
Oh my gosshh.
Good job, Frog.
Ah, great. We have handicapped Spider-man on our side.Great.
I meant it, Spider-man. I meant it 100%
Alright, we'll use Spider-man as shield.
Just follow him.
What are you doing, Spider-man?
Use your Spider web...
OHMYGAWD, Spider-man saved my life.
Thanks, Spider-man.
How about a Spidey-hug?
You saved my life.
He's a hero.
Nice.
Got 'em.
Goooot 'em.
Nice.
Alright, I should probably go live.
How's it going, bros?
Oh, my gawd.
Dude, you're PewDiePie.
Oh, my god. Are you PewDiePie?
Oh, god. That's too close. Please, stop.
Is that a t[h]yre?
Are you- tyred?
Oh. god.
No, I'm not PewDiePie.
Why would you think that?
Oh, god.
OHMYGOD, Scooby got wigs!!
Hey, it's me.
What the *oof* are you?
That's- definitely how I pronounce my name, thank you.
Okay, well, I'm not planning to. Jesus.
What the *oof* it's crashing?
You came out of a person?
That's gay.
What's up?
That was beautiful.
Clap it up for Kerm-
Kermit.
Beautiful.
10 years of practice, that was all it took?
Hey guys.
What's up? It's LouiGi here.
Hey, Whaaa
Ah, cool.
Ay, you promised you won't tell me.
Hey, shut up.
Listen, we had a deal, oaky?
It was between me and him.
You're a *oof*ing Penguin.. Shut up. I won't even judge you from here.
Hey, look. I'm one of you guys.
What is the *oof*ing meme, I forgot.
WOAH
How do I DO this?
Ah, hell.
OOH
I have powers.
Did you just- Did you just lick my ass?
Al right, well it's a new body.
There's a new sheriff in Madagascar.
He ain't playin' around and I don't care who's handicapped.
Come back here, Spider-man.
Spider-man, I don't care if you're in a wheelchair. You're gonna die, Spider-man.
That's what you get.
AAHH
Ah, you suck ass.
Who else wants some?
Ay, careful.
*oof*itch
Congratulations, band aids. Well done.
Just wanna say, big congrats.
Hey, Spider-man.
We're the same now.
Do you nod away, Spider-man?
Hey, can we touch?
Can our- can our tiptoes touch?
Oh, I like that.
Spider-man, I know what you're going though, all right?
Alright, Spider-man is angry.
Come on, Spider-man you're going with me, alright?
Got 'em, Spider-man.
You want some of this spider?
You want some of this?
You want some of this? Hey, where are you going? Come back here.
Spidey's got two guns loaded for ya.
Come out over your head, and no one gets hurt.
Hands above your head and we won't shoot.
I sway. I dance.
Dance for Spider-man.
I mean- It had to be done. I'm sorry.
It's a Spider-rule.
You should know this, Spider-man.
You should know this.
Hey, let's stretch our legs again. Let's stretch our legs. I like that. Come on.
Let's flap 'em together.
Look at my legs, dude.
He's got a bomb adhuehd!! NOOOO!!!
Yeaaahhh...
Ahhhh
Oh, that guy.
OOh, thanks.
BoBs Or VeGaNa, WhIcHeVeR wIlL iT bE
SiT tHe *oof* DoWn T-sErIeS, i'M hErE tO sPiLl ThE rEaL tEa
Yes.
Oh, yeah.
Are you subscribed to PewDiePie?
Are you sure?
Good.
Sit down, take a seat.
Right here.
Take a seat right here.
Oh, okay. There you go.
WHHAAAAAA-
Ah
Yo
Yo, come here.
You *oof*ing piece of shit, how dare you?
You will all pay for what you did-
Who took my knife??
Gimmme the gun.
Gimme the gun.
Gimme the gun, stop it.
Just gimme the gun.
GIVE-ME the gun.
Oh my gawd.
Ad Pewds: You want pyramids?
We got 'em.
Oh, you're into castles, huh?
We go you covered, baby!
You want some pets?
EASY!
We got-it all.
This game is still relevant, goddamnit!
=D